forsberg gets some help to get it back to Center
and Kane had it lost him now punched up the middle
to forb he Taps it to himself now tries to get
it back he does backhander stop by Campell rosi
around the back of the net met there by Warren
FAL loose Puck Novak has it Novak can clear it
bouncing pu picked up save made by Yo by yussi
SAR a stick goes flying and a penalty call is
coming up it'll be interference on the Predators
power play will get on the ice here it is y see
just he got hit behind the beside the net so
this might have been on the young seasar now
it's McDavid on the near side rard two Dres
SLE Here Comes McDavid back to the other side
Always Mobile Ryan Nan Hopkins looks for to
the side of the net one timer score dry Sidle
strikes well Leon dry sidle that's 21 goals
in 12 games against the Nashville Predators
and he moved over from that spot went through the
middle of the ice and opened up for that one time
and the movement here watch Hopkins down low right
there Hyman I think it is right out to dry cidal
and heyman's a net front guy but he moves down
there to get that passing play there as dry Sidle
one times out right under the bar the Adam Ernie
in his first year with the ERS a late knee this
one batted ahead and Evangelista comes in Luke
Evangelista to the trailer no back can't beat
cbell he went for the top Corner KCK a hard hit
penalty call coming up on the Oilers and forsberg
on that right flank what retrieve Novak Yosi right
at the top that's his normal position no back
top of the circle fires th save Campbell sharp
early looks determined to bounce back from his
rough first outing now Newen Hopkins challenging
with h the shot blocker to side by Soros retriev
by dry cidal worked over to Bard Bard gets it
back puts it right into the traffic T home by
highman ridle and Hyman involved in both goals
need a lot of possession to hurt you and you
look at a great interchange there watch this
interchange up high look at dry side he's coming
all the way for right all the way over nice little
give and go and then they're just going to put it
to the net front and let's see who tips this Puck
here heyman's in front all the time I think it's
Nan Hopkins over to Heyman and he's right there
waiting on the doorstep it is nen Hopkins Brown
engaged with two Defenders Evangelista goes
down O'Reilly comes in to try to help out F
loose right in the slot the shot by EOL stck there
Point Blank by Soros those two players why just
to watch when they get the puck their head is
always up for a rebound and another save for k
Campell who's been razor sharp Nashville battles
to get it back and another big save for Campbell
Nashville buzzing around creating turnovers imman
and nen Hopkins have been a big part of the story
so far kulak taken out of the play Puck loose in
the Predator Zone skating over his Hyman hman in
his third GE Puck picked up by Warren F back
door score what a pass by fogal and it's three
nothing Edmonton D Hopkins waiting on the back
door and you can see right here this is a big
goal Yosi gets tangled up here and here come the
Oilers again you mentioned Fogle with a little
stop and shimmy pulls that Puck and then Newen
Hopkins waiting he gets lost in coverage Yosi
right here trying to attack that post this just
a second too late Kane retrieves tried to shoot
it blocked by carrier he for sure would fed it to
the middle but see how quick McDavid can get back
and here he comes the other way tried to get
around MCD he's got it here comes McDavid he
scores well it's Halloween season and Nashville
has been haunted National Hockey League look
at him right now he's just SK now he sees he he
smells the blood in the water he's going to battle
here and the puck just goes right by and he just
pulls his hand out and he just gets it up and up
they had a minute more Zone time than the Emington
Oilers but they turned the puck over they gave it
away 11 times put the puck in their hands and they
paid the price the Vegas golden knights we'll see
how things go it's it's early for those kind of
picks but right now early in the season the goal
tending and maybe the defensive side of the game
still an issue for the Oilers oh ry's got a man
open no back from the slidey [Applause] scores the
Predators get what they need Tommy Novak connects
his second power play goal of the year it's 4-1
and the novaki look at this pass O'Reilly opens
up and then twists beats no back left-handed
shot he turns that love the patience of Novak
there in the slot he didn't rush it he picked
the spot and nailed it now Nyquist gets into
the open ice fires save big by Campbell with the
pad but another penalty is coming up after this
one look at night go they get possession they're
gone they're out of the Zone he cuts in there's
the hook and then scorpion Sav by Campbell nqu
speed he has him beat right there and he gets
that Pat up nist gets elevation has Campbell beat
but a desperation save a nice desperation save re
by O'Reilly to the middle left lets it go no back
again tries to drag it still loose down on the ice
is kolap Ted over one timer off the post the post
o rilly had the open net and he got iron O'Reilly
hitting the post that would have been huge if
he could have buried that get some momentum
off of this now turning to the middle Evangel
still lose C looking for thomasino can't make
a play on it Nashville fends it off and they've
got the puck again Smith attacks pass broken up
taken back by Ryan mlau he's got a man open to
Vander Kane CL save by lanen Faceoff coming up
with 38 seconds to go in the forsberg penalty what
scan O'Reilly will take it one back by dry Sidle
McDavid playing catch out High Bard that hit and
the rebound goes right to dry Sidle who hits the
back of the net forsberg the penalty and the
Oilers make him pay it's MCD who blocks it but
it goes right to dry cidal right on his stick
he's at a bad angle look at bdon puts his body
on line dry cidal takes it collects it and then
just lifts it up and over the pad of Lankin in
there under the glove he's we saw the shot chart
throw bur tracks it down his next pass is stolen
by evangela head for Novak Novak joined by Yosi
Novak backand or stopped by Campbell and the puck
goes off his stick blade good job there by It
Go on one in the puck oh H away gets it alive
Conor Brown to the point kulak a shot save made by
Lincoln and rebound available picked up by Brown
pass along the goal line hard hit in that corner
CL by the Predators that was siss open man Fogle
tees it up and he scores way too much time and
space and fogal beats lanin it for a 6-1 lead
hton gets the puck down and and they move it so
well there was just a lot of space great here
nice little play Puck protection had the puck on
their stick and think it's Tyson Barry there kind
of loses his footing there pass across and Fogle
just rips it has time to dust it off see there
Heyman that's Hopkins over to Fogle rebound track
down by Barry his pass however didn't have much on
it glass tries to get there can't do it and now a
three-on-one developing Ryan looking onetime earn
then a great save by [Applause] leny let's go
to Cara Hammer she had a chance to talk to Todd
Richards after the second period thanks will I
caught up with Coach Richards and I asked him
what he wanted to see out of this guy this third
period and and ready to go for that Rangers game
but you can't play that once you finish this
period so this is all that matters right now
there's Warren Fogle who's had a nice night he
fires and hits the post rebound blocked Final
5 Seconds ticking down broberg clears and
there's the final horn so Nashville gets 42
shots but they fall 6-1 the big four goal first
period too much to overcome for the Predators